[موسيقى]
راينا من بعيد رجلا يجري نحو سياج مزرعتنا
يطارده اناس كثيرون
حسن قبل ان يقتل على يد مجموعه من الغواء
ضحيه اخرى لمرض تفشى في انحاء الهند
جريمته انه مسلم اما المرض فهو الكراهيه
اثناء رحلتنا عبر شمال الهند ومن المسافه
صفر شاهدنا كيف تعيش الاسر من الاقليات
والمسلمون خصوصا حياه يملاها الرعب ذهبنا
الى ولايه اسام في الشمال الشرقي البعيد
حيث تبنى معسكرات احتجاز من يطلق عليهم
المهاجرين غير الشرعيين المشتبه بهم بما
في ذلك 700 الف مسلم الى حين ان تقرر
المحاكم اذا كان يجب ترحيلهم ام لا هند
هذا لا يحدث مع الهندوس المسلمون فقط من
يعتقلون
[موسيقى]
حيث تهاجم حشود الهندوس اليمينيه المتطرفه
بعض رجال الشرطه الذين حاولوا التصدي لهم
اثناء محاولتهم الهجوم على تجمعات
للمسلمين
امسكوا به من الخلف واطلقوا النار عليه
بمسدسه الخاص
وصولا الى مومباي اكبر مدن الهند
حيث يزعم مسؤول سابق في منظمه اجراميه
تروج للتفوق الهندسي انه تدرب ليكون
ارهابيا لاستهداف المسلمين بالطرق مختلفه
بتعليمنا صناعه القنابل اصبحت نوعيهم
واضحه لقد ارادوا تنفيذ تفجيرات في جميع
انحاء البلاد
سيموت الناس خاصه المسلمون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نيودلهي عاصمه الهند الصاخبه يبلغ عدد
سكانها نحو 15 مليون نسمه يمكن لك في
شوارعها ان ترى كل التناقضات الفقر والبؤس
والثراء كل شيء في المدينه يشي بتفاوت
طبقي ملحوظ
ما تفاخرت الهند بكونها اكبر ديمقراطيه
انتخابيه في العالم دوله تنعم بحريه
التعبير وباعلام غير خاضع للرقابه يقف
جميع المواطنين فيها على قدم المساواه
وفقا للدستور
هكذا كانت
اما اليوم
الحكومه على وسائل الاعلام بشكل كبير
وتقوم بتقييد وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وتحضر الافلام التي قد تنتقد الحكومه
وتعتقل شطاء حقوق الانسان باعداد كبيره
بينما تخشى الاقليات الحديثه على نياه
غير مرحب بالكثير من الصحفيين في الهند
اضطررنا على مدار اسابيع للتنكر كسياح
واستخدام ادوات تصوير الهواه في بعض
الاماكن لتشتيت انتباه السلطات والتحرك
دون تدقيق في هوياتنا
[موسيقى]
بالقرب من وسط دله يقع معبد اللوتس احد
اكثر المناطق جذبا للازدحام في المدينه
[موسيقى]
بني هذا المكان ليكون رمزا للتعايش بين كل
الاديان والطوائف في الهند
لكن الترويجه لهذه المثاليه الحالمه
تفندها الاحياء المسلمه القريبه من هنا
[موسيقى]
هذا احد الاحياء التي يسكنها المسلمون
الذين يشكلون اكبر اقليه في الهند بنحو
200 مليون من اصل نحو مليار و400 مليون
نسمه بات الحلم العلماني الذي تغنت به
الهند وسعت لتحقيقه محض خيال وكابوسا
يلاحق الاقليات التي تعيش في مثل هذه
الاماكن
انا الان في طريقي لمقابله شاب مسلم كان
على اتصال مع والده لحظه مقتله
[موسيقى]
بينما كان يدرس محمد صابر لامتحان
الالتحاق بالخدمه المدنيه تلقى مكالمه
هاتفيه غيرت مجرى حياته الى الابد
في نحو الساعه السابعه وخمسين دقيقه مساء
تلقيت مكالمه من والدي لكنه ظل صامتا
وبقيت اردد مرحبا مرحبا لكنه لم يرد خفت
قليلا خصوصا انني كنت اعرف ان والدي سيعود
بمفرده لكن من هؤلاء الاشخاص الاخرون في
السياره
عمل افتاب عالم والد صابر سائق سياره اجره
في دلهي لنحو 15 عاما كان يخصص كل روبيه
تزيد عن حاجته لتعليم الصابر وشقيقيه شاهد
وشاهد في طريق عودته الى المنزل بسياره
الاجره اقل ثلاثه رجال اشاروا له من على
جانب الطريق في المدير
اجيب شعرت بشيء مريب في الطريقه التي
كانوا يتحدثون بها كانوا يطلبون من والدي
ان يشرب ربما كانوا يشربون الخمر في
السياره وعرضوا على والدي ايضا لكنه رفض
سالوه عن سبب رفضه فاجابهم بانه لا يشرب
الكحوليات ارادوا معرفه السبب وسالوه عن
اسمه وعندما اخبرهم بان نسمه وافتاب قالوا
له لهذا السبب لا تشرب لانك مسلم
مخاوف صابر عندما طلب احد الرجال من والده
ترديد عباره يعلن فيها الولاء للديانه
الهندوسيه
[موسيقى]
قريبا بعد نحو خمسه عشر دقيقه من المكالمه
طلب احد الاشخاص من والدي وقف السياره حتى
يتمكن من قضاء حاجته اوقف والد السياره
وسمعت الباب يفتح بعد ذلك لم اسمع شيئا
كان الهاتف قد بقي في السياره بينما
اخرجوا والدي خارجها
من الاسوا وهرع الى المنطقه
من فوري الى المكان مع جدي وعمي رايت
سياره والدي متوقفه على جانب الطريق وكانت
الشرطه وصلت قبلنا
تعرفت على السياره وسالتهم عن والدي قالوا
لي انه في المستشفى
وقد اصيب باصابات طفيفه
[موسيقى]
سالته ضابط الشرطه كيف حدث ذلك قال لي انه
قتل وترك في السياره ووجدوا جثته بجانب
مقعد السائق مربوطه بحزام الامان
كيف تعاملت معك الشرطه عندما
ذهبت الى هناك
طلبوا مني تسجيل افادتي كشاهد لكن الافاده
كانت مكتوبه بالفعل قالوا انها لا تبدو
جريمه كراهيه بل قضيه سطو وهم يحققون فيها
لكنني رايت محفظته في السياره كانت هناك
في السياره
لقد وثقنا بان الشرطه ستؤدي عملها على
اكمل وجه لكن مر الان اكثر من عامين ولم
يحدث شيء لم يلقى القبض على احد ولم
تساعدنا الدوله ولا الحكومه المركزيه
[موسيقى]
في كل يوم جمعه يزور الاخوه قبر ابيهم
الذي علق عليهم امالا كبيره وما زالوا
يبحثون عن العداله له لما كان يدرك ان
قدره ان يكون سائق سياره اجره لكنه علق
اماله على اطفاله كان يريد لهم النجاح في
هذه الحياه ارادنا ان نصبح اطباء ومهندسين
وان نعيش حياه كريمه لا يغيب عن بالي ابدا
اعيش حياتي بهذه الذكريات لان والدي
اخبرني ذات مره ان الحياه لا تتوقف لاحد
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت قضيه افتاب عالم مجرد حادثه
فرديه فلن تكون اقل صدمه لشده عنفها لم
يعد ذلك استثنائيا على الاطلاق في ظل شيوع
الهجمات الوحشيه وجرائم قتل المسلمين في
السنوات الاخيره
ناشطه هندوسيه ضمن مجموعه تسمى متحدون ضد
الكراهيه تعين علينا الصعود الى مكتب بانو
جوتسنا بحذر وفرادى اذ يعتقد ان المكان
يخضع لمراقبه مستمره من قبل السلطات بعد
ان تم اعتقال العديد من زملائها واصدقائها
بالفعل جنوب
لم يبدا العنف ضد الاقليات المسلمه في عهد
حكومه من الواضح انه كانت توجد حالات كانت
توجد اعمال شغب وقعت مذابح قبل وصول حكومه
مودي الى السلطه لكن ما حدث بعد وصول
حكومه مودي الى السلطه كان عدم تدخل
السلطه لوقف الغواء
تشكلت متحدون ضد الكراهيه عام 2017 بعد
حادثه مقتل الفتى المسلم محمد جنيد في
طريق عودته الى المنزل للاحتفال بالعيد
والتي حظيت بتغطيه واس في الهند
لقد كان مجرد شجار بدا بين الركاب في
المقاعد لكنه تحول فجاه الى قتال قبيح
للغايه حين جرى تمييز الصبي كان من الواضح
انه مسلم صبي في السادسه عشر من عمره
فوقوه وطعنوه عده مرات تعرض لاكثر من
اربعين طعنه بينما استمر اخرون بضربه رغم
اصابته حتى توفي على متن القطار عفت بعد
مقتل جنيد اندلعت احتجاجات كثيره وخرج
كثير من الهندوس للاحتجاج قائلين انتم
تعلمون ان ذلك لا يمثلنا
منذ ذلك الوقت والاحتجاجات مستمره بدعم من
طلاب الجامعات من جميع الاديان الذين
يتعرضون للقمع والضرب المبرح من قبل
الشرطه
[موسيقى]
بقي المسلمون في ولايات شمال الهند واحده
تلو الاخرى موضع استهداف وغالبا ما اجبروا
على تمجيد رام وترديد هتاف جيش ريغرام قبل
تعرضهم للضرب او القتل
قتل محمد جنيد بولايه هاريانا نفس الولايه
التي قتل فيها مسلمان حرقا في ديسمبر 2020
لكن ذلك بات واقعا في كل مكان في الهند
قتل هذا الرجل في ولايه بهار
مثل هذا في ولايه جاركند كان هذا الهجوم
في ولايه مد برادش
قدرات
راجستان
هذه الجرائم ليست سوى غيظ من فيض لجرائم
اخرى كثيره لا يتم الابلاغ عن اغلبها
على مستوى محلي حيث لا تتعامل الشرطه مع
القضايا بعد ان تقع جريمه قتل او اعدام
على يد الغوغاء او يكون خطاب كراهيه يجري
تقديم ذلك علنا للدعوه الى العنف
والاغتصاب والاباده الجماعيه
[موسيقى]
حتى عند فتح محضر في قسم الشرطه فانها
غالبا ما تسجل تحت مظله جرائم الجنح
والجنايات مثل السرقه او الاعتداء او
الاخلال بالنظام العام لكن الحزب الحاكم
ممثلا في المتحدث باسمه سودان شومتال يصر
على ان الجميع متساوون في نظر القانون
نحن بلد يؤمن بسياده القانون فالكل خاضع
هنا لحكم القانون كائنا من كان اذا اختار
احدهم ان يتصرف خارج اطار القانون فسيعاقب
بشده
انه ليس من مهمه الحكومه توجيه المحاكم
ربيها لدينا قضاء مستقل للغايه في هذا
البلد لا يمكن للحكومه الحاليه التدخل في
العمليه القضائيه لكن ان رفعت قضيه مفادها
ان المحاكم لا تحاسب الجناه فان الحكومه
تتحمل مسؤوليه ذلك ولا اعتقد ان هذا الامر
خاطئ
لكن الشرطه تحقق في الجرائم
وتقدم الادله للادعاء يقول سانجيه هيجري
احد اكبر المحامين في المحكمه العليا في
الهند ان الشرطه تخضع للتاثير من اعلاه
بان الشرطه الهنديه نتاج التجربه
الاستعماريه لقد حكمنا البريطانيون وتاسست
الشرطه في اثناء الحكم البريطاني وبالتالي
فقد اعتادوا دائما تلبيه اوامر الحكومه
ايا كانت لذا فهم دائما يقدمون تقاريرهم
الى السياسي ايا كان في السلطه وهم غير
مستقلين ويخضعون بالكامل لسيطره الحكومه
ان الحكومه الحاليه لديها اجنده معينه
تنتهجها
الحزب الحاكم بالتاكيد لا يحب الاقليات
ولا يحب الاشخاص الذين يؤكدون وضعيتهم
كاقليه هو لا يحب اي شخص يفكر بشكل مختلف
وبفضل التوحد في صفوف الاغلبيه فانه لا
يحتاج حقا الى اصوات الاقليات للفوز
بالانتخابات ليس لديهم حتى نائب مسلم واحد
كجزء من الحزب الحاكم يوجد عدد قليل جدا
من المسلمين او المسيحيين الذين هم في اي
موقع قوه اليوم ولكن قبل وقت ليس ببعيد
كان للهند رئيس مسلم ورئيس وزراء من السيخ
وكان رئيس الحزب الحاكم مسيحيا انتهى كل
ذلك الان
مع غياب تاثير الحكومه وحمايه الشرطه تجد
الاقليات نفسها تحت رحمه الحشود الغوغائيه
اصبحت الابقار التي تتمتع بقدسيه خاصه لدى
الهندوس سببا لهجمات ما يسمى بحراس البقر
بشكل متزايد والذين يزعمون بدورهم انهم
يتصرفون وفقا لقوانين حمايه الحيوانات
يجب استغلال قوانين حمايه الابقار ايضا
لتصوير غواء ما يعرفون بحراس الابقار كقوه
منفذه لهذه القوانين يقولون مثلا كانت مع
فلان بقره وشككنا في انه لا يملك الاذونات
اللازمه فذهبنا لضربه ومات
ما كان سمي الدين يرعى حقله بالقرب من
منزله وقع هو الاخر ضحيه احدى هجمات حراس
البقر
راينا من بعيد رجلا يجري نحو سياج مزرعتنا
يطارده اناس كثيرون
منا بدا الغوغاء ضربه
الذي يضربونه من اجله
انكم وهذا الرجل تذبحون البقر اخبرناهم ان
ذلك عار عن الصحه تماما وانه لا يوجد بقر
هنا ولا حتى ادوات ذبح
اذا كنت لا يوجد سكين ولا فاس ولا اي اداه
اخرى لا توجد اي وسائل لفعل اي من هذا
قالوا له انتم مثله وحلفائه تذبحون البقر
ثم انهالوا علي بالضرب ايضا
[موسيقى]
هل يمكن ان تاخذني الى موقع الحادثه
نعم بامكاني ان اخذكم الى هناك بكل تاكيد
لقد تعرضنا للضرب بالعصي والهروات والمضرب
والطوب والطين الجاف لقد تعرضنا للضرب حتى
فقدنا الوعي ثم بداوا سحبنا نحو قريتهم
واي شخص قابلناه من قريتهم
وحلفائهم يضربوننا اكثر
كانوا يضربوننا وكنا نسقط على الارض ثم
يعيدون الكره مرارا وتكرارا
تم جرو الرجلن عبر الاراضي الزراعيه
باتجاه القريه الهندوسيه حيث كانت مجموعه
من الرجال بانتظارهم ليسعانهما ضربا الى
حين وصول الشرطه كان كلا الرجلين قد فقد
وعيهما قامت الشرطه بنقلهما في سيارتي جيب
بشكل منفصل ليجد سمي الدين نفسه في
المستشفى
هي ثم نقمنا الى مستشفى جي اس خرج شخص من
سياره الجيب التي كان قاسم بداخلها واتجه
الى السياره التي كنت فيها ثم اخبرنا ان
قاسم توفي
في راسي جرح كبير واذني كانت ممزقه كانت
يدي مصابتان بجروح كثيره وكذلك ساقائي لم
يكن في جسد مكان لم يتعرض للضرب او لم اصب
فيه بهذا
الرئيسي في القضيه والمحمي من الشرطه بشكل
دائم بقرار قضائي لزياره زوجه قاسم وشقيقه
في بلده هابور المجاوره
[موسيقى]
رقم كل شيء فهذا عصي على النسيان
وكلما بقيت وحيده افكر به ضرب الزوجه من
القرويين
حاول وقفهم لكنهم ضربوه ايضا انه شخص طيب
حاول سمي الدين انقاذ اخيه وضرب بينما كان
يحاول انقاذه لقد حاول حمايته لقد سعى
جاهدا لانقاذ اخيه وانا اشعر الان بانه
فرد من العائله
[موسيقى]
لا تزال عائله قاسم تامل في تحقيق العداله
لكن فرص ذلك تتضاءل
معظم القضايا تنتهي دون نتيجه لا تزال
القضايا مفتوحه لسنين طويله ولا عداله
تتلوح في الافق
الحكومه القوميه الهندوسيه الحاليه تفجرت
عمليات العنف من قبل من يسمعون حراس البقر
في الهند اذ قتل اكثر من 50 شخصا في
السنوات القليله الماضيه كان معظمهم من
المسلمين
نوم لم يكن احد بامانه كان المسلمون هم
الهدف الاول ولكن لم يكن احد في مامن من
الهجوم فقد قتلت قبائل مسيحيه في كثير من
الاحيان حتى الطبقه العليا من الهندوس لم
تسلم ذات مره كانت تجمع الاسلامي الكبير
اجتماع الذي يقام في بولند شهر اتى اليمين
الهندسي المتطرف وقد كانوا يلبسون الزي
الخاص بهم وحاولوا تنفيذ بعض اعمال العنف
والشغب لكن الشرطه تتدخلت وبسبب فشلهم
بداوا مهاجمه الشرطه وقتلوا المفتش
سبوديسينج
لا استطيع ان انساه في حياتي لا يمكننا
ابدا ان ننساه
شيء انتشرت في مواقع التواصل عن ذبح ابقار
في مزرعه قريبه من المهرجان
[تصفيق]
دفعت المتطرفين الهندوس الى المنطقه بحثا
عن الانتقام
اتصل زوجي برؤسائه مرات عده لطلب قوه
اضافيه كان يوجد نحو 600 شخص من المحتجين
في مواجهه اربعين او خمسين من رجال الشرطه
الذين كانوا هناك لردعهم
هؤلاء لم يبقى منهم في النهايه سوى ثلاثه
رجال شرطه او اربعه كانوا من مركز الشرطه
الذي يعمل تحت امره زوجه اما الاخرون فقد
هربوا خشيه رؤيه الاسوا كان زوجي يخبر
الناس المتجمعين هناك بانه لن يسمح باي
اضطراب في المنطقه
وسيوقفهم حتى على حساب حياته ولكن الى اي
مدى يمكن لشخص واحد ان يصمد امام 600 شخص
لن تنسى ما حصل بعدها
مهاجمون غضبهم على زوجها
هذا الغواء قطع الطريق لجمع مزيد من الناس
ولكن زوجي منعهم وخلال ذلك اصيبت يده كما
اصيب بجروح عميقه في مؤخره راسه بعدما
ضربه احدهم بصخره بعد ان اصيب براسه بدا
ينزف بغزاره لذلك ذهب الى حقل بجانب
السياره
هناك احاط به الناس واستولوا على سلاحه عن
طريق الخداع
امسكوا به من الخلف واطلقوا النار عليه
بمسدسه الخاص
ه كانت زوجته في حاله صدمه عندما سمعت
الخبر لاول مره
حد منهم دفع مقتل المفتش سينغ الشرطه الى
العمل ليتم القبض على المشتبه بهم
الرئيسيين لم يمر وقت طويل
حتى افرج عن المتهمين بكفاله بل واحتفل
انصارهم بعودتهم من جديد
اشعر بضيق في صدره عند التفكير في كل هذا
اشعر بالخجل احيانا اولا نخلق مثل هذه
الشياطين ثم نشكو من انها موجوده ويجب
القضاء عليها الا يمكننا وقف هذه الممارسه
في وطننا
[موسيقى]
المتهمون بقتل المفتش سنج واولئك الذين
رحبوا بهم باكاليب الزهور ما هم الا اعطاء
في حركه اتخذ مؤسسوها من زعيم الفاشيه
الايطالي بينيتو موسوليني وادولف هتلر في
المانيا مصدر الهام لهم
[موسيقى]
منظمه الاتحاد الوطني الهندوسي ار اس اس
هي المنظمه الفاشيه الاطول بقاء في العالم
[موسيقى]
المؤرخ والكاتب ديريندر درس منظمه الاتحاد
الوطني الهندوسي المعروفه بار اس اس وهي
منظمه هندوسيه شبه عسكريه تاسست عام
هدفها الرئيسي هو تحويل الهند الى امه
هندوسيه عرس الاتحاد الوطني الهندسي ار اس
اس هي منظمه سريه للغايه لا تحتفظ باي سجل
عضويه لم تسجل حتى في السجلات الرسميه
على اساس الرمز
يديرون الاف الشعب وهي فروع يجذبون اليها
الاولاد الصغار ويلقنونهم عقائدهم وعندما
يكبر هؤلاء الاولاد يصبحون جزءا من احدى
الجماعات التي تتحكم بها المنظمه
[موسيقى]
في كثير من الاحيان يتم القاء اللوم على
مجموعات اخرى مثل منظمه المجلس العالمي
للهندوس في اتش بي وجناحها للشباب المسمى
بجرا دال
ولكن وفقا لموقع ار اس اس الالكتروني فان
كل هذه المنظمات مرتبطه بشبكه واحده
[موسيقى]
تحاول من خلالها التاثير على قطاعات
مختلفه من المجتمع
احبكم
الان اصبحت هذه المجموعات منظمات كبيره
جدا على سبيل المثال اكبر نقابه عماليه في
البلاد
مهاراتها
هي جناح منها اكبر حزب سياسي في البلاد
حزب بهارات يا جالاتا هو كيان منها ايضا
كل ما تفعله حكومتنا يتوافق تماما مع ما
تريده منظمه ار اس اس
هل الدوله في الهند تدار من قبل هذه
المنظمه ار اس اس
اداره البلاد عبر اذرع ار اس ووفقا
لمبادئها
كتب زعيمهم الاكثر تسجيلا
بعنوان نحن او تعريف وطنيهنا عام
وكان جولو الزعيم الثاني للاتحاد الوطني
الهندوسي
يقارن الكتاب مشروعه
النازيه تنعز
ويقول بوضوح ان المسلمين لا يستخدم كلمه
مسلم بالطبع
[موسيقى]
ولكنه يقول الاقليات لكنه يعني بوضوح
للمسلمين والمسيحيين وما مثلهم يجب عليهم
اما قبول اولويه الهندوس واما البقاء هنا
مواطنين من الدرجه الثانيه
كزب الحاكم والعضو في ار اس اس ايضا يسر
على ان القياده الحاليه ترفض هذه الفلسفه
دي حلف على اساس قرا رئيس ار اس اس في
حوار علني استمر ثلاثه ايام وشاركت فيه
وسائل الاعلام انظروا الى ار اس اس في
سياق اليوم وليس في سياق عام
1925 عندما تاسست او
لان السياق السياسيه والاجتماعيه كان
مختلفا عليكم ان تقولوا ما الذي نؤمن به
اليوم ويقول في معتقداتنا اليوم ما قيل
ذلك الوقت ليس جزءا من معتقداتنا اليوم
يؤكد بان منظمه ار اس اس الحاليه تعامل
جميع الاقليات على قدم المساواه
هذا هو السبب في انها غير التمييزيه حيث
يستفيد منها المسلمون والمسيحيون وكل
الفرق كما تنتفع منها القبائل وافقر الناس
ومن خلالها ينتفع حتى الناس الذين ينحدرون
من ادنى الطبقات الاجتماعيه وهذا يمكن
رؤيته هذه هي حقيقه ار اس اس لكن لا احد
يريد النظر الى هذه الحقيقه
في ولايه اسام التي يديرها الحزب الحاكم
تم تقديم قانون جديد للمواطنه الذي قد
يؤدي الى طرد مئات الاف المسلمين من الهند
ليس لدينا اي مكان نذهب اليه نحن هنود حتى
لو ذهبنا الى مكان اخر فهل تقبلنا اي دوله
لا هند لا يحدث مع الهندوس المسلمون فقط
من يعتقلون
وبعيدا عن الامطار تاخذ السلطات الهنديه
زمام المبادره من الصين تنتشر معسكرات
الاحتجاز لمن يسمونهم المهاجرين غير
الشرعيين في جميع انحاء الريف
الاجنده كما ترى اجنده بسيطه ان كنت تريد
المسلمين او لا المسلمون يجب ان يرحلوا
والمسلمون الناطقون بالبنغاليه المقيمين
في اجسام خصوصا
يحاول المحامي المسلم حافظ تشدهري في
اجراء قانوني يائس وقف السجن وترحيل ما
يصل الى 700 الف مسلم يعيشون في ولايه
اسام بموجب السجل الوطني للمواطنين الذي
تعرض لانتقادات شديده
باعتبارهم مهاجرين غير شرعيين
يجب ان تكون لديك شهاده ميلاد يجب ان تكون
لديك شهاده مدرسيه يجب ان تكون لديك وثيقه
ملكيه للارض الان السؤال عن مخاوف
المسلمين يوجد بعض المسلمين الاميين الذين
ليس لديهم ارض ولا تعليم لم يذهبوا الى
مدارس ولا يملكون شهاده حتى انهم لا
يملكون شهاده ميلاد لذلك لا يمكن لهؤلاء
الاشخاص اظهار مستنداتهم هؤلاء الناس
فقراء جدا انهم افقر الفقراء
حتى الان هناك سبعه مراكز اعتقال نشطه في
ولايه اسام تحتجز عددا غير معروف من
المسلمين ما يعرف حتى الان هو ان واحدا
وثلاثين على الاقل من الذين اقروا انهم
اجانب لقوا حتفهم خلف القضبان في ظل
اتهامات لحكومه الولايه بانتاج اليات
تعذيب واستجواب قاسيه داخل مقرات الاحتجاز
ومع ذلك اعتبرت حكومه الولايه التي يديرها
حزب بهارتي اجانتا الحاكم المشروع ناجحا
كما تخطط لتطبيقه فيما لا يقل عن عشر
ولايات اخرى في جميع انحاء البلاد
التواجد الامني في مدينه اسام واضح علي ان
اظهر كسائحه في المدينه كان من المفترض ان
اذهب الى معسكرات اعتقال لكن الامر صعب
وخطير للغايه
قبل وصولنا الى هنا اتصل بنا ثلاثه من
المرشدين ليخبرون انهم لم يعودوا قادرين
على مساعدتنا بسبب خوفهم من الاعتقال
تقع ولايه اثام على حدود بنجلاديش وبوتان
مررنا على نقاط التفتيش اكثر من مره هنا
ومع المراقبه المشدده من قبل الشرطه بات
العديد من نشطاء حقوق الانسان خلف القضبان
ذهب فريقنا متخفيا ووافقت مجموعه من اتحاد
طلاب الاقليات على اصطحابه لمقابله بعض
الضحايا في قريه دورانجا بالقرب من الحدود
مع بوتان
اضطر الفريق الى اخفاء الكاميرات وسلك
طرقا وعره لتفادي نقاط التفتيش
وصل اخيرا الى وجهته
بنيت هذه المنازل اعلى التل
واقيم اسفلها معبد هندوسي بني حديثا
اول من قابله الفريق صمد علي وزوجته فاطمه
مثل كثيرين من سكان هذه المنطقه يحترف صمد
الاعمال اليدويه مبتعدا عن التدخل في حياه
الاخرين استمر ذلك الى ان تلقوا زياره غير
متوقعه في منزلهم ذات يوم
جاءت شرطه الينا ذات يوم لم يظهر لنا اي
امر قضائي او وثيقه رسميه فقد طلبوا منا
الحضور الى مركز الشرطه وعندما سالتهم عن
السبب قالوا ان قضيه رفعت ضدنا سالتهم ما
القضيه لكنهم لم يجيبوا
رغم عيشه في الهند طوال حياته وبدون ان
تقدم السلطات اي دليل اتهم صمد بانه مهاجر
غير شرعي ليلقى به مع كثيرين ممن لم تجد
صرخاتهم اذانا صاغيه في معسكرات الاحتجاز
انه ليس معسكر بل سجن يجبروننا على الدخول
الساعه السادسه مساء وفي الخامسه صباحا
يسمح لنا بالخروج
ولا يمنحون سوى نصف ساعه لاستنشاق الهواء
والذهاب الى الحمام
لا يسمح لك بالخروج خارج السجن ولا
بمقابله افراد عائلتك الموجودين في الخارج
يمكنك فقط رؤيتهم من مسافه بعيده
واذا احضرت عائلتك طعاما مطبوخا في المنزل
فلن تحصل عليه ياكله السجانون نكثنا في
المعسكر سته اشهر وثلاثه عشر يوما
هنا انتشر الخبر عن وجود فريق الجزيره
فبدا الضحايا بالتوافد الى المكان اثناء
اجراء المقابله حسبما اوضح لنا فريق
الطلاب فان لدى الجميع قصصا يرونها
نحو الساعات الثالثه صباحا جرى نقلنا الى
كوكاجار نقل الذكور الى جواربرا والاناث
الى كوبراجور
في الذهاب الى مركز الاحتجاز لان لديها
طفلا يبلغ من العمر سنه ونصفا ولا يمكنها
تركه وراءها لكن الشرطه فصلتها بالقوه عن
طفلها ووضعتها في سياره الشرطه وقتها
بعيدا
ظللت ابكي وابكي تركت طفلي البالغه من
العمر سنه ونصفا في المنزل استمر حليب ثدي
في الزياده واعطيت علاجا لتقليل ادرار
الحليب
بالنسبه لجميع الموجودين هنا لا تمثل
محاولات خروجهم من معسكرات الاعتقال سوى
بدايه الحكايه وبسبب فقرهم تعين عليهم بيع
ممتلكاتهم ليتمكنوا من دفع اجور محاميهم
يقولون ان قضيتنا ستستغرق اكثر من عشر
سنوات جرى التاكد من ان والدتي وابي هنود
كل اخوتي واخواتي هنود فقط انا وزوجتي جرى
تصنيفنا بنغلاديشيين لقد انفقنا ما يقرب
من 150 الف روبيه على القضيه والاوراق فقط
لي ولزوجتي تناها الى مسامع الفريق وصول
السلطات الى المنطقه فكان لابد من مغادرته
ولكن ليس قبل طرح السؤال الاخير
[تصفيق]
اذا لم يكن الخوف من الاعتقال والترحيل
كافيا فقد تحولت الولايات والمقاطعه التي
يديرها حزب بهارتيجنطه الحاكم الى طريقه
فريده لقمع الاقليات وابقائها تحت السيطره
توجهنا الى مدينه كارجون
اشتهرت المدينه سابقا بكونها اسرع المدن
حركه في الهند
اما اليوم فتشتهر المدينه بهدم منازل
المسلمين وشركاتهم
السلطات خراط مجموعه من كلا الطائفتين
الهندوس والمسلمين في اعمال العنف الا ان
اعمال المسلمين التجاريه وحدها التي تتعرض
للتدمير والتخريب
ما يحدث في فلسطين يحدث هنا يشغلون
الجرافات للاشتباه بهذا الشخص او بتهمه
تورطه في اعمال العنف وبالتاكيد دون اي
قرار محكمه دون اي شيء
ميرا مصنع امجد خان دون سابق انذار
فقط لانني مسلم لا توجد قضيه ضدي لقد
جاؤوا الى هنا ودون اي اشعار او امر من
المحكمه وهدموه لست انا فقط لقد هدموا
ممتلكات عديد من المسلمين في هذه المنطقه
فقط ممتلكات المسلمين ما جرى هدمها
من واحد هدمت السلطات قرابه 50 منزلا
ومحلا تجاريا مملوكا لمسلمين السبب الرسمي
هو ادعاء هش يزعم بنائها بشكل غير قانوني
ياخذنا امجد للقاء حسينه التي تعيش الان
في كوخ مستاجر بعد هدم منزلها تخبرنا حسين
ان بناءها المهددم ليس فقط بني بشكل
قانوني بل وحصل على دعم حكومي ليتم انشاؤه
وافقوا اولا على منزلي واعطوني المال
لبناءه اعطوني 100 الف روبيه ثم خمسين الف
ثم مره اخرى 100,000 وكان ذلك في اطار
مخطط الاسكان الحكومي علاوه على ذلك وضعت
كل الاموال التي املكها وبنيت منزلا لكنهم
لم يسمحوا لي باكمال بنائه
وصلت الجرافات دون سابق انذار
لوث البقر اولا وقفت امام البوابه اطلب
منهم عدم هدم المنزل
قم اين اذهب زوجي متوفى ليس لدي اي ارض في
اي مكان اين اذهب باطفالي
لقد استعملوا ثلاث جرافات لهدم منزلنا لم
يرحمونا ولم يسمحوا لنا حتى باخذ اغراضنا
لقد
لقد اردت ان اموت هناك ولم اعد ارغب في
العيش ولا اعرف الى اين اذهب الان اريد ان
اموت
[موسيقى]
لقد تلقى المجرمون في جميع انحاء البلد
عقوبات هدم منازلهم في مناسبات مختلفه
انتم تنتقون مناسبه معينه حيث كانت هناك
مجموعه من الناس متورطه في هذا الامر
لماذا لم يقم الاخرون بذلك اذا كان هناك
مجموعه تجاوز القانون فقد تمت معاقبتهم
ايضا تاخذ ولايه مادي براديش الخطوه
الاولى
وتحذوا الولايات الاخرى حذوها تباعا
فعلى سبيل المثال تستهدف الجرافات في شمال
ديله حيث يحكم حزب بهرت يا جانتا شركات
المسلمين بشكل اساسي
لا يوجد شيء في اطار سياده القانون يسمح
باستخدام الجرافات فكره تشغيل الجرافات ضد
الاشخاص الذين تعتقدوا انهم لا يستحقون
التعامل معهم بموجب النظام القانوني هذه
فكره بغيضه هذا مخالف لسياده القانون
جاءت عمليات الهدم في دلهي بعد ايام قليله
من العنف الطائفي في نفس المنطقه عندما مر
موكب هندوسي مسلح بالسيوف بمسجد في المكان
وحيثما تحدث مواجهات نادرا ما تغيب اعلام
الزعفران البرتقاليه الخاصه بالاتحاد
الوطني الهندوسي ار اس اس عن المشهد
ولكن هل هناك جانب اخر غير مبلغ عنه
لانشطه ار اس اس واتباعها
يتتبع المؤلف ديرن دجها قصه ار اس اس الى
منطقه اكثر خطوره
بدات وكالات التحقيق تدرك ان رجال المنظمه
متورطون بانشطه ارهابيه توجد مزاعم تتعلق
بالتدريب على استخدام القنابل
[موسيقى]
اكبر مدن الهند المركز المالي للبلاد
وموطن صناعه افلام بوليود
منطقه سكنيه يراقب احدهم الشارع من كل
الاتجاهات تحسبا لاي هجوم مفاجئ
بعد كل خطوات في الخارج اجول بنظر لارى
وجوها جديده واحيانا اشخاصا مجهولين
يحدقون من بعيد
لا ازال حذرا لانني اعرف ان المخبرين
ياتون الى هنا لمراقبته
وهو عضو سابق بدوام كامل في ار اس اس انه
يعيش في الوقت الضائع بعد ان اختار الكشف
عن دوره داخل المنظمه
يدعم يشونت انه تلقى تدريبا لتنفيذ عمليات
ارهابيه سريه بما في ذلك المشاركه في مخيم
تدريب على التفجير خلاله واوائل العقد
الاول من القرن الحادي والعشرين
واتهم شخصيات بارزه في ار اس اس بتدبير
العمليه
حسب قوله فان الحكايه بدات في معسكر في
جمو بولايه كشمير بعد دعوه من الرجل الذي
يقف على يمين الصوره اندرش كومار
العضو الحالي في الهيئه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
كنت على اتصال مع اندرشين وكنت التقيه كل
شهر تقريبا طلب مني احضار مجموعه من 11
رجلا او 12 من ولايه ماهر اشترى لمحاربه
الارهابيين
جمعت بعض الشباب واخذتهم الى
جاموغو
كان في الصباح تدريب بدني وبعض التدريب
الذهني ايضا وقد جرى التدريب تحت اشراف
الجيش
تعرفنا على الاسلحه مثل
47 واس ال ار وكاربن وتدربنا على كيفيه
استعمالها والتعامل معها بعد كده كانت
الخطه تنفيذ حوادث غير مرغوب فيها مثل
جرائم القتل هكذا كانت خطتهم يتذكر شندي
ايضا كيف تلقى طلبا غير متوقع بعد عودته
الى المنزل
تلقيت دعوه في عام 2003 كنت في مومباي
وقتها وعرض علينا تعلم كيفيه صنع القنابل
وتنفيذ المهام سالتهم هل هذا استعداد
للانتخابات عام 2004 التي كانت تفصلون
عنها حينها سته اشهر او سبعه هل تريدون
اعمال شغب صمت ذلك الشخص تساءل كيف عرفت
التزمت الصمت ايضا لكنني قبلت الهرب في
سنها غاد فيبيون في المنتجع الموجود تحت
الحصن جرى تدريبنا لمده ثلاثه ايام على
صنع القنابل توافرت بعض المكونات مسحوق
ومصباح وانبوب وسلك وجهاز توقيت وقطع من
الحديد جرى استخدام هذه المواد لصناعه
القنابل ثم استخدم ناها انا فعلت ذلك
بنفسي
بهي اللحظه التي بدا فيها الانقلاب على ار
اس اس
بتعليمنا صناعه القنابل اصبحت نوعيهم
واضحه لقد ارادوا تنفيذ تفجيرات في جميع
انحاء البلاد سيموت الناس خاصه المسلمون
رفض شندي لكنه زعم ان المشاركين الاخرين
ذهبوا قدما في حمله التفجير
اكتشفت فيما بعد انه في بورنو
وبارباني انجز هيمان شوبانسي المهمه واجر
استطلاعا في اورجنبات كانت تلك خطه اخرى
اجروا زياره اولا فينانديد حيث كان يعيش
كل منه
شوبانسي حيث يصنعون القنابل لكنها انفجرت
وماتوا على الفور
تم تاكيد عضويه الرجلين المتوفين في
مجموعات ار اس اس
يزعم شندي ان زملائه المتدربين قاموا
بتنفيذ حملات تفجير اسفرت عن مقتل اكثر من
120 شخصا على مدار خمس سنوات
معظمهم من المسلمين
حصلنا على تقرير هام صادر عام 2020 من قبل
وكاله التحقيقات المركزيه الهنديه حول
تفجيرنان يؤكد التقرير شهاده بشان معسكرات
التدريب وصنع القنابل بما في ذلك اسماء
متدربين اخرين نقلها مسؤول ار اس اس
السابق تتطابق نتائج التحقيق ايضا مع وقت
ومكان معسكر بونيه الذي درب شندي فيه
وقدر رفضت جميع الطلبات التي قدمها
للادلاء بشهادته في المحكمه بالنسبه لرجل
كان يؤمن ذات مره بالتفوق الهندسي فان
وجوده داخل النظام غيره الى الابد ويذكر
المسؤول الحالي لخدمه ار اس اس بما قاله
ذات مره
قلم هام بهجوات مرات عده ان الحمض النووي
للهندوس والمسلمين هو نفسه اتساءل اذا كان
الحمض النووي هو نفسه فلماذا يحرضون بعضهم
ضد بعض لماذا يفعلون هذا اذا كان لدينا
نفس الدم فلنتصرف بهذه الطريقه اليس كذلك
تزداد الحياه صعوبه بمرور الوقت على 200
مليون مسلم في الهند
لكن لا يزال هناك العديد من الهندوس الذين
يعتقدون ان المسلمين جزء من هويه الهند لا
يمكن استئصالها
[تصفيق]
لم يتخلى الناس عن مفهوم الديمقراطيه
وفكره العلمانيه عن الفكره التي قامت
عليها الهند انها معركه مستمره ونامل
النقاتل وان شاء الله ننتصر في هذه
المعركه
اذا كنتم تعيشون جميعا في هذا البلد
فعيشوا معا بحب ما الذي يجلبه سفك الدماء
[موسيقى]
التاريخ
الحضاره وسحر الطبيعه
ما يريدون ان نراه فقط في الهند لكن في
الحقيقه ان كل ذلك ذات مهددا بعد ان ضرب
عفن الكراهيه والتطرف جذور البلاد فالى
اين تتجه الهند
[موسيقى]